the jurogan experience are you aware of
the controversy surrounding the
male mona lisa do you know the story
about this the melalesa
no no yeah it's um there's the most
expensive painting
ever sold it was sold for 400 million
dollars
to uh the bin salam
what is it excuse what is his name
muhammad bin salam
the am i saying his name right the head
of saudi arabia
mbs okay what is his actual name though
i'm sorry
i think you were close i [ __ ] it up
it's probably brian saunders
muhammad bin salam no chris salman
yes okay the mbs the the head of saudi
arabia bought it for 450
million dollars this is it and
the crazy thing is someone bought it at
one point in time in the past
i want to say for fifteen hundred
dollars
and they didn't realize that it may or
may not be because this is where it gets
controversial
may or may not be the work of leonardo
da vinci so it was
it was restored so do the history of
this the controversy in the history
about it yeah there's a great there's a
crazy history to it
um where someone bought it for an
extremely low amount then a russian
oligarch
bought it for over a hundred million
dollars see 1 175
at an attic sale in new orleans for a
dirty painting that he hadn't even seen
after a painstaking restoration i think
took a decade
some began whispering that it might be
the by the master himself
so an art dealer in 2005 paid one 1
175 dollars for it so 16 years ago
someone paid a thousand 175 dollars for
the most expensive painting ever sold
so then this guy go down scroll down i
can't get this
um there's a bunch of other articles
that are free that you could read about
it but it's uh
it's a crazy story so this this person i
believe started working on it in 2005.
started the restoration and then by the
time
i think it was around 2015 they started
realizing like
holy [ __ ] because i guess sometimes in
the past
someone would take a great painting and
they would paint over it
yes which is crazy yeah and so then
there's this insanely
painstaking restoration project where
you're removing
layer upon layer upon layer what
sixty dollars this was sold for in 1958.
sixty dollars so it gets even crazier
yeah this is an article from 2017 where
it was on auction for even less than
it was just sold for it yeah so it was
knocks for 100 million
then and that's when it was bought by
the russian oligarch
before mbs bought it so is the
controversy that the person who
originally bought it should get a
kickback because now you know the value
no here's the controversy the
controversy is it may not be
by leonardo da vinci at all i see and or
it might be
partly by da vinci and so google this
there's a scan of the image and i don't
understand the technology involved in
the scan but the scan apparently
revealed that there's
more than one era of painting or there's
more than one application of painting
meaning that more than one person worked
on it
at more than one time like an exquisite
corpse
it's hidden withdrawal so this might not
no no this doesn't reveal it this is not
it
it's it's about there was a digital scan
of that painting what is it called again
it said male mona lisa i don't know it's
right there's another name for it okay
there's a there's a name for that
painting i forget what it is but
salvator mundi mundi yeah salvatore so
when they did the scan there's something
about the hands and the way the paint
is done on that in relation to the rest
of it that it's like
you know they're talking about like
[ __ ] microns
they're measuring depth and layers and
age and all sorts of different [ __ ] and
they're trying but well you're dealing
with 450 million dollars for a [ __ ]
painting
jesus so it gets down to this
dispute there's a long page about it
okay see if you can see this
the images because there's images of the
uh the analysis
if you scroll down it's a beautiful
painting yeah it's very beautiful
but there's there's images is that what
it used to look like on the right
i think that's what it used to look like
and then they slowly but
surely restored it to the point where
it's at now
um was that what it looked like so
versions of it people would
yeah there's more than one version of it
so people would buy
paintings like you know 100 years ago
500 years
ago and just [ __ ] start scribbling on
it
paint over it yeah so they had to go
over these things
to restore them like insanely
painstaking
like i said it took like 10 years
to to restore this i see i see they're
doing like this this is a
what do you call a cross section yeah
analysis yeah
wild [ __ ] yeah because they have to find
like what is the original paint color so
they have to find the original layer
exactly so that's what it used to look
like imagine that
and then they bring it from that to what
you see now like look at that
wow crazy so what does that mean then do
they paint over it like
how do they do that i mean does someone
paint over the old paint
and make it look better is that better
like isn't it better to be scratchy and
all [ __ ] up
and the original painting i know i know
it's it's yeah i guess it just depends
on what you want right i mean
but that's the problem with this
painting so after all that
after buying it for 450 million dollars
it's currently
in controversial dispute as to whether
or not it's actually the work of
leonardo da vinci
makes sense they he they wanted him to
uh donate it to the louvre in paris yeah
but they were like we're not going to
put it next to the mona lisa he wanted
it to be next to mona lisa as the male
mona lisa mona lisa the male model so
they're like
they're like we don't we don't we're not
going to give this the red stamp we
don't even know if this is real
wow yeah interesting yeah it's just oh
man could you imagine that
that feeling of being rejected like that
and you're like imagine exactly
you're that guy i mean this is the guy
that allegedly killed
uh khashoggi yeah yeah for criticizing
his regime
yes um and have you ever seen that movie
the dissident which is
an incredible movie but brian fogle that
details
all the the the events that took place
oh no i haven't seen that crazy but so
he's the one that's in possession of
this painting and now it's currently on
his yacht
so this 450 million dollar painting is
on his yacht
and so art fanatics are like you can't
have
a painting on a yacht like that that's
for not just that that can the climate
like to have these right the sea water
yes to have these paintings i mean maybe
he only had it for a day or maybe he
only had it like to tell everybody he
had it there yeah he actually has it in
a
like a human yeah i imagine he would i
mean come on i don't know i mean he's
falling out of his mind he's
buying 450 million dollar paintings he
might be paying on it right now but
that's nothing that that's nothing he
might do whatever he wants
he can do whatever he wants if you've
got the kind of money for a 450 million
dollar painting
but it might not be it might not be
legit and apparently
so i go down a rabbit hole apparently
there
is a massive market for illegitimate
paintings and people get robbed all the
time and there was in fact a guy
who was a master there's i believe
there's a documentary about him
who there's a big one on netflix about
this right now i thought that's what
you're getting
like the master forgers well there was a
guy
who was that was his trade what he would
do was
make fake picassos so he would make his
own work
but in the style of picasso and they
would
claim that this was a lost picasso
wow and he sold these things for
millions and
millions of dollars this is the netflix
one this lady got made you look
they found she was selling fake [ __ ] for
a long time
oh okay i didn't i messed a lot of
people off i've not seen that one
but there's a guy who was he did time
and he got released eventually and he
did time
for creating fake masterpieces
and it's really crazy because the guy
was insanely talented
right his art was magnificent right
right right
but it wasn't for michelangelo but he
conned people yeah
yeah i mean the art was great but he
conned people but it was
it's it's weird it's like it's so my
uncle said this to me once
this is really a funny thing because
when i was a kid i would pretend i
brushed my teeth
right but i i really didn't brush my
teeth and my uncle
uh my uncle vinnie who's a really
interesting guy he's a very creative guy
as an artist and
he said it's funny because i used to do
the same thing but once
eventually i realized i put so much
effort into pretending that i brushed my
teeth
that i could have just brushed in my
teeth with that same amount of effort
and i wouldn't have to pretend and i
thought about my god damn he's smart
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other
apps and can download episodes to save
on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience